in my things you missed episodes on the
final destination franchise i've pointed
out some of the hidden signs of
impending disaster
in final destination 5 this caution sign
can be seen ahead of the bridge
and what looks like a simple peeling of
plastic from wear and tear is actually a
warning of the titanic bridge collapse
that would follow as usual there would
be connections to the disaster that the
franchise is based around
the crash of flight 180. the bus that
they're on is called roland coach lines
roland is a french name that's a french
name
and the logo features a bird feather a
reference to flights and the memorial of
the flight's 180 crash
the video that plays inside the bus is
from 180 corporate consulting and the
bus number is 1-2-8-2 the sum of whose
digits add up to 13 the unlucky number
that we've seen arise in every final
destination movie
the main character sam also known as
nick 2.0 sees a vehicle labeled taggart
logging truck number two
taggart is a reference to the taggart
theater an accident location in the
fourth movie and number two is a
reference to final destination 2 which
notably had a huge accident involving a
logging truck
just like this one and the license plate
of this chevrolet matches carter
horton's car that gets destroyed in the
first movie
then there's nathan's line about his
employee roy which is another possible
death omen
but i want him over even if it kills me
to learn all of fd5 secrets including
the clues about the movie's twist ending
stick around to the end of this video
this video is sponsored by nordvpn
oh my sound the alarm alert the media
because cz is actually finishing a movie
franchise he started on things you
missed
i've got to make sure that youtube comes
down to tape this
the fifth and final of the original
tri-annual final destination movies was
directed by stephen quail whose last
name sounds like a combination
of quesadilla and something you would
put on your salad this is why i should
never write these episodes when i'm
hungry let's get into the things you
missed
the story begins outside the offices of
pre-sage paper the word presage is no
accident it's defined as a sign or
warning that something typically
something bad will happen
it's also probably no mistake that this
is a paper company because the boss of
presage paper a man named dennis lapman
is played by actor david kochner who
many will recognize from his role at the
time in the us television sitcom the
office where he plays todd packer he was
pretty much the same character as dennis
you're welcome merry christmas oh wait
oh you're kidding me
he also seems to have bought himself an
exec of the year mug much like how
michael scott has a mug that says
world's best boss in the office
the license plates also tell us that
we're back in new york where final
destinations one and two took place
sam and his girlfriend molly are having
some relationship issues
molly your ticket's cancelled
tell me that's a mistake i was gonna
tell you after this weekend it's not
working out sam
well that was a waste of a travel ticket
if you've seen my previous episodes on
the other movies
you know the drill luck chance and fate
are always referenced in these movies
because being caught in a disaster is
seen as bad luck and many of the victims
are superstitious candace has a pair of
lucky rubber bands
oh it's um it's just something i do to
relax
and for luck and it snaps right before
her accident
the new station that reports on the
bridge collapse is on channel 13 the
unlucky number the survivors are
referred to as the lucky aids
and although they've been branded the
lucky eight though
eight is usually not considered a lucky
number as bradley donovan can probably
attest to
isaac steals a gift certificate for ming
yoon spa ming yoon is the concept of
personal life and destiny in chinese
folklore
and before his treatment he rubs the
buna statue's belly which is also seen
as an omen of good luck
ironically it's that same statue that
winds up being the end of him
olivia also taints her own fortune
shortly before her demise by knocking
over a picture frame on her desk
more on that later the coach bus comes
up onto the north bay bridge and we can
see that it's a long way down to the
surface
final destination 5 also brings back the
concept of a recurring death omen song
dust in the wind by kansas this may be a
reference to the tendency of death to
materialize in the form of a gust of
wind
we've seen the winds of death in
relation to many of the accidents but
perhaps none more than the bridge
collapse which was said to be the result
of high winds and structural damage
caused by the construction
chalking up the high winds and
structural damage from the road
construction
high winds in the scene where the bridge
gives way there are many undetected
clues about how each survivor would meet
their face for example
isaac dies while laying on his stomach
in the premonition and he would be in
the same position at the massage place
when death catches up with him olivia's
fate is essentially sealed once she
loses her glasses in the vision a clue
about her real final moments which are
spent in a procedure
to correct her vision the premonition
shows her surviving the bridge fall but
ultimately being done in when a car
falls on her her actual doom is the
opposite
after her eye is mutilated by the laser
she does her best aunt maggie and falls
down several stories onto a car
several characters have to make their
way across a steel beam to get the
safety a foreshadowing of the balance
beam accident that ultimately got
candace bent over backwards in the
vision candace does fall to her death
which he technically does in the gym as
well
peter gets impaled by stakes just as he
is when sam skewers him a la carte and
sam is chopped in half much like what
happens to molly when she's dissected by
the wing of the airplane
nathan's death isn't really foreshadowed
in the vision but there would be a very
interesting secret hidden
in one of his time cards
the holiday season has arrived and you
know what that means
well if you're like me it means horror
movies just like
all the other months of the year and
when you're watching a lot of horror
movies you may start to exhaust the
selection of your streaming service of
choice what if you could unlock a bunch
of new movies
just by clicking a button with nordvpn
you can do that
i'm going to use netflix as an example
right now i'm in the u.s event
literally trapped here no other country
will accept me now with one click i'll
change my location let's do france and
honor a final destination
look now we've got all the movies the
french people can see you can keep doing
this for all the other countries or you
can look up which country you need to
set it to to see a specific movie
of course that's just a benefit of
nordvpn the main point is to encrypt
your web traffic so that nobody knows
about the data that you're sending or
accessing online now as a cz's world
viewer you're going to be getting a
special
holiday deal where you get a two-year
plan with four additional months
free just go to nordvpn.comworld and use
coupon code cz's world at checkout
the news reports that presage paper has
eight survivors but the other 17
employees perished in the collapse there
must have been some people stowed
underneath because i do not recall
seeing 23 people on that bus
surprisingly this movie doesn't really
keep up with the tradition of the names
of the deceased being the names of the
crew members on the movie only one of
the last names matches a name in the
credits
and johnson is one of the more common
american names there are two graves in
the background that correspond to the
names of previous final destination
characters carpenter could be to
represent nora and tim carpenter from
final destination 2 and clark was one of
the police officers from final
destination 3 although
these can't actually be their tombstones
because those characters haven't died
yet
while the crew reference easter eggs
tradition may have been like oh the
tradition of something wildly
inappropriate happening at every funeral
goes on strong
for isaac palmer you just say my name
that's not funny
this is of course a reference to the
iconic line from the sixth sense
i see dead people if you like references
to freaking great 90s movies this is the
entry for you because another can be
seen later at the office in the form of
these cubicle sticky notes spelling out
always be
closing the iconic sales mantra from
glengarry glen ross
a b c a always
b b c closing always be closing
always be closing of course the final
chapter of the original pentology of
final destination would contain a fair
share of references to the other films
when sam visits molly she's boiling
water which was part of valerie luton's
death in the first one
in the gymnastics scene a potentially
electronically charged puddle creeps
towards candace's foots like the puddle
on todd wagner's bathroom
sam's cubicle has a toy motorcycle
similar to eugene's motorcycle and fd2
the motto born to ride references the
opening
of each movie which all feature
disasters of a ride of some kind and
isaac flirts with a girl on the phone
named kimber tell me the kimber from
last tuesday
this could have maybe been kimberly
corman from final destination 2.
also this has nothing to do with the
story at all but did anyone notice as
sam is getting out of work there's this
truck
just completely bastardizing the parking
job i mean the person is almost
completely up on the curb what the hell
speaking of hell there are usually a lot
of references to hell or the devil in
relation to the deaths i think there's
only one new one in this movie it comes
when the rogue factory guy roy fails to
take mr crab's warning into account
they're back they're back
and gets himself bobby dagen right
through the skull the end of
pokes through the top of his skull like
a devil's horn after seeing this
peter is very shall we say curious about
the circumstances of the accident
did you didn't you hey peter calm down
did you
or didn't you did you or didn't you
think i did i never understood why he
would say that
anyway the first tragedy after escaping
the bridge is candace's gymnastics
mishap she speaks with her boyfriend
before going on and walks out from
section 108 in the stands an anagram of
the cursed flight number 180. earlier i
mentioned
the wind being a symbol that death is
among the characters and we've seen it
in many forms in the series starting
with the fan in alex browning's bedroom
in the gymnastics scene we see a fan
brought in because the air conditioning
is broken
and it contributes to taking out candice
another bad sign that can be found in
the scene is an ac plug which looks kind
of like a skull the ambulance that shows
up is u1575
u is the 21st letter of the alphabet so
if you add that to the other digits 1
plus 5 plus 7 plus 5
you get 39 which matches the amount of
mount abraham
high school students who pass away on
flight 180. the next day at the office
not that the office some of the
remaining presage employees return to
work
in each movie i've mentioned how the
character names correspond with
filmmakers who had an impact on the
horror genre it is here that we find out
about a few more
olivia castle is named after the great
william castle peter friedkin is named
after the great william friedkin
and candace hooper after the great toby
hooper olivia's eye doctor is named dr
leonetti this may be a reference to john
leonetti a notable horror movie
cinematographer that would go on to
direct five horror films in a row after
this
isaac palmer is named after betsy palmer
who is probably most well known as
pamela voorhees
isaac does some snooping around the
office and steals a gift certificate
from his late co-worker the expiration
date is 6 301
if we multiply 6 times 30 times 1 we get
the number that's come up time
and time again 179 i'm just kidding it's
180. this certificate number also ends
in 810 which is an anagram of 180.
isaac hurts his finger while retrieving
it just as sam did on the bus and on the
plane
meaning that this would be a sign that
isaac's hours are numbered nathan brings
up a case of adult beverages if you've
watched my other final destination
videos you already know it's coming it's
a six pack of heist pal
the fizzy but fatal refreshments that
foreshadow disasters in the last three
final destination movies
but the office would contain another
important final destination callback
ft5 lacks the volume of crew reference
easter eggs that the other movies have
but i did spot one more in the presedge
office
in olivia's work area there's a
memorandum to the board of directors
from adrian pritzk
he is final destination 5's graphic
designer i already mentioned olivia's
broken picture frame but what i didn't
bring up is the photo itself
it's a ride photo from devil's flight
it's a roller coaster that would crash
five years later during the events of
final destination 3. they claim it's the
world's scariest roller coaster
movie is set in 2000 about two weeks
before millennium force would open but
i'd still probably give it to oblivion
at that point in time
the next death is isaacs that's the
massage place
yum yum dim sum and the only other thing
that i'll say about this
is that the no cell phone sign seen in
the lobby may count as an actual warning
from death considering that his phone is
actually what causes the fire
after that is olivia at the eastfield
laser eye center and her sign comes when
she's squeezing the teddy bear for
comfort and its eye pops off
the same happens to her not long after
out of every scene in the franchise i
think this is the fatality that affected
me the most
sam recalls his vision to try to
remember the order that they were
supposed to die in where we see
probably my favorite part why do they do
that
don't they know that slowing stuff down
makes it funny
the next death is supposed to be nathan
who's still having problems with an
employee named roy he does a little
snooping using security camera 32 the
reverse of 23 as in route 23.
also just gotta say for a security
camera that definition is freaking
incredible
i mean look at that most security
cameras you can barely even see phase
bank's bald spot
but on this thing you can zoom right
into the hairs on roy's chin i gotta get
me a camera like that
the dx8100 probably another anagram of
the flight number 180 with an extra zero
attacked on
the finale involves peter coming into
the restaurant that sam works at to take
molly's life so he can theoretically add
her years to his own
don't get me wrong i love this scene
it's very satisfying to have an
actual antagonist after nearly five
movies i just think the way he goes
about it
is kind of hilarious he just invites
himself in
pours himself a huge glass of wine and
then goes all badlands chugs on it
and then peter chases them into the
kitchen and
wait why is he turning on the friars is
he planning on deep frying molly
this is gonna be the best kill ever
[Music]
as you may know two-thirds of all final
destination debts involve water or
liquid i think this comment on my ft4
episode puts it best
water is the source of life on this
planet without liquid water we would not
be here
it is fitting that a liquid starts all
of the death the movie started when the
north bay bridge collapsed into the
water candace's final college practice
would become her final ever practice
thanks in part to the dripping water
from the air conditioner isaac
didn't exactly get his happy ending
massage because the bottle of
disinfectant alcohol falls starting a
typical final destination flammable
liquid incident
olivia's fun and games end when her
water or rather her water spills onto
the outlets causing the laser surgery
machine to malfunction
simon molly's plane crashes into the
atlantic ocean and nathan meets his fate
at a bar
of course whenever i talk about final
destination 5 people tell me that they
were blown away by that twist ending
pun slightly intended 5 was actually my
first final destination movie because my
friends told me you don't have to watch
them in order
liars so i had no idea what was going on
when they boarded flight 180 at the end
and i was kind of pissed when i found
out that it was ruined for me just so we
could watch that movie that night but
upon re-watching i noticed at least
nine different signs some of which may
be kind of obvious that final
destination 5 was in fact
a prequel not a sequel i'll start with
the opening credits they contain a
montage of other disasters we've seen in
the franchise and when flight 180 blows
up it emits this metal beam in a v
shape v is the roman numeral for 5.
final destination 5 would contain flight
180. we've also got to take into account
the title of the last movie it would be
a bit strange to make a movie called
the final destination only to follow it
up with a sequel a few years later
however making ft5 a prequel allows the
final destination to remain
the final destination chronologically
sam is an aspiring chef and the next
clue comes when he reveals that his
restaurant wants to send him to an
apprenticeship in paris
they want to send me to the flagship
restaurant in paris for who knows how
flight 180 was a trip to paris france
the restaurant that he works for is lake
cafe miro 81.
this is the very same name as the
restaurant whose dislodged sign took out
carter horton at the end of the first
final destination had he ever made it to
that job he would have been working at
that very same restaurant
then there's the return of william
bloodworth i went into more detail on
this and my horror history episode on
bloodworth but basically he stopped
showing up after final destination two
so his presence may suggest that we're
actually in the past
more evidence that we're at the dawn of
a new millennium can be found in the
gymnasium at west dell college where
recent looking championship banners are
hanging from 1994
in 1998 but nothing past the year 2000.
then in the office there are a couple of
clues
the first is more of a bad omen a
miniature model of the vulit aircraft
can be seen sitting on the cubicle walls
and when isaac steals robert's spa
certificate the expiration date can
clearly be seen
and it's in 2001 and then when he tries
to use it it works
implying that 2001 has not yet arrived
later on in nathan's office we see the
actual date as he's collecting time
cards for the week ending in april 30th
2000.
this is just two weeks before the date
of the volit flight 180 crash which took
place on may 13
2000 in the sequel universe as i've
discussed before there are two
continuities
in the original the crash takes place in
1999 and in all the sequels it takes
place in 2000.
oh god i have thought a lot about that
somewhere alex
it exists that place so the day of the
flight arrives and sam and molly take
their seats in row 23. there's that
number from fd2 again i did go back to
the first movie to see if the people
sitting in those seats resembled sam and
molly at all
they don't there's a brown-haired man in
molly's seat and a brunette woman in
sam's
which begs the question why don't they
just cast characters who look like these
rather than cast someone who looks
exactly like nick from the last movie
none of the other passengers resembled
the passengers from the original flight
180. for example
this is where billy hitchcock should be
actually there are a lot of
inconsistencies
like how the plane is now one row
shorter than it was in the first movie
or how the gate number on sam's travel
ticket is h6 but we clearly see it's
gate 46 in the first movie he's seated
in 23j
according to the way that the seats were
mapped in the original he should have
actually been 23b
these could be mistakes and they may be
but these small changes can be explained
away with the idea that the sequel
universe changes little details from the
original the final signs for sam come
too late he once again hears the death
omen song from the opening
dust in the wind and molly's magazine
has an ad for eastfield laser eye center
where olivia died you'd think the
ensuing male practice suit might have
gotten them shut down
the final scene shows the final survivor
nathan attending a memorial for roy
dustin the wind can be heard playing in
the background
[Music]
and in one of the photos in the shrine
we see that roy is a fan of the race car
number six the car that causes the big
speedway accident in final destination
4.
there's another ft4 reference when this
guy tells nathan that roy didn't have
long to live anyway
[Music]
we saw this same phrase on the back of
someone's shirt at the racetrack
finally before the franchise would be
laid to rest for the next decade they
just had to squeeze one more heist pill
el logo
there has been a lot of talk of a final
destination six and i'm gonna be doing a
video breaking down the possibilities
for that new sequel so make sure you're
subscribed to cz's world for new horrors
every week ring the death bell for
notifications and i will see you in the
next one
assuming we both survive if you want to
beat death use a face mask and
social distancing